we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P
here is a question about trans youth and
surgery puberty blockers
etc etc and it's targeted at me based on
something a viewer thinks I was I guess
deliberately doing the other day take a
listen
David I just watched uh
covering of the status Christ debate uh
when it got to the part about uh
uh transitioning uh transgender kids I
noticed you were pretty quiet uh where
are you on uh kids under 18 and uh you
know teenagers 13 14 15 taking uh
puberty blockers
and uh
uh taking other transitioning hormones
and uh
um in some cases uh
uh you know the medical uh surge surgery
that does it yeah
um like uh taking out their breasts or
genitals and um
uh did you support it as a gender
affirming care or do you think that uh
uh if you're under a certain age it
should not be uh should not be given to
kids okay so listen I was not being
deliberately quiet for any particular
reason my view on this issue of trans
youth puberty blockers gender affirming
surgery trans teens five to seven year
olds versus 12 to 14
Etc my view is there are so many
different situations that need to be
dealt with
differently
and
I am not an expert in that and so I know
that it has become really in for every
podcast host and streamer and whatever
to take hard and fast positions on every
aspect of this if and when are puberty
blockers okay and what about the surgery
and then claims about oh hospitals are
trying to convince people to transition
and all of this stuff that's not backed
by any actual kind of evidence that it's
taking place my view on this is what I
currently believe
the overall
position of experts medical experts to
be not religious clergy not Republican
or Democratic politicians and that is as
follows
you need a multi-pronged approach when
it comes to
trans youth people under 18.
there are medical aspects to this there
are social aspects to this there are
educational aspects to this there are
mental health aspects to this there are
policy related questions that have to be
answered
I don't pretend to have all the answers
and I believe that a lot of the specific
elements of this are still being studied
what I can tell you for sure is that
we're not going to get to the best
outcome for the trans youth by allowing
Republicans to set the terms of the
debate
to ban all sorts of things again as if
they know better than doctors which
we're familiar with them when it comes
to abortion and on and on and on now I
will also say the left
should not dismiss parts of the
conversation that they don't like I'm
going to give you an example here okay
here's an example of something that I've
seen some on the left dismiss
it should be explored
weather
when
a 15 year old says I believe that I am
in the wrong body when it comes to sex I
was born biologically male but I feel
that I am a woman
it should not be dismissed
that maybe that is a reflection of what
is happening in society
for someone who is struggling with
something but it may not necessarily be
that they were born into the wrong body
and what I mean by that is
it should it should be explored whether
there are deeper components to what is
going on and because of what is
taking more attention in the media right
now some folks are being drawn to that
now I know some of you will say David
are you saying there shouldn't be gender
affirming no no no there should be
absolutely everything but it should also
be a conversation that is being had and
by the way it is had when people want to
transition there are conversations with
mental health professionals the right
likes to pretend someone says after 15
years of living as a boy they say I'm a
girl and two days later they're having
surgery that's not happening that's not
happening but the point here is
all aspects of this should be considered
all aspects of this should be considered
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today we are going to talk about the
supposed trend of quiet quitting quiet
quitting I have a lot to say about this
and I've read quite a bit about it many
of you have emailed me saying David you
should discuss this we will today
the world's dirtiest man has died in
Iran at age 94 what does that mean the
world's dirtiest man I will tell you and
the Nazi holding a Kanye is Right sign
on the 405 freeway in California has
been identified and the situation is
very quickly getting very very ugly I
want you to sign up for a membership at
joinpakman.com and then you will get
instant access to the bonus show thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
Dave Pacman well you don't have to be me
you can just listen to the bonus show
and that's good enough joinpakman.com is
the place to sign up you can use the
coupon code big voting22 to get a
sizable discount and I look very much
forward to seeing you then